in a basketball game the giraffes scored
13 fewer points than the Penguins the
Penguins scored the Penguins scored 87
points how many points did the giraffes
score now before we even try to do this
let's just think that based on what they
told us well the giraffes
score more points than the Penguins or
less points than the Penguins well they
tell us the giraffes scored 13 fewer
points 13 fewer fewer points than the
Penguins so the giraffes scored less
points than the Penguins so whatever
number is here the giraffes this is
going to be less than 87 because the
penguin scored 87 points and how much
less is it well it's going to be 13 less
it's going to be 13 fewer so this right
over here this right over here is
whatever the penguin scored
whatever the penguin scored which they
tell us is 87 can they tell us the
penguin scored 87 points and it's going
to be 13 fewer than that or 13 less than
that so it's going to be 87 minus 13
points so let's figure out what that is
so the Penguins scored 87 points and the
giraffes scored 13 fewer so if we
subtract 13 from the 87 that's going to
give us the number of points that the
giraffes scored so what is that going to
be let's see let's look at the ones
place 7 ones minus 3 ones is 4 ones and
I go to the tens place eight tens minus
one 10 is 7 tens so 13 fewer than 87 is
74 points and the giraffes score 13
fewer than the Penguins this is the
Penguins this is what the penguin scored
right over here
the giraffe scored 13 fewer than that so
that is going to be that is going to be
74 74 points and it makes sense 74 is 13
fewer than 87